we begin with that tragic story the
deadliest fire in New York City and 27
years it ripped through a five-story
apartment building last night one block
west of the famous Bronx Zoo 12 people
were killed including four children and
that number could rise the ages of those
who died range from 1 to 63 the cause of
the fire is unknown survivors inside the
building were forced out into the bitter
cold with no warning Don Dahler is at
the scene of the fire in the Bronx Don
good morning good morning police
officials tell us that the investigation
is active and ongoing and of the at
least 12 people killed five were
pronounced dead here at the scene which
indicates that the flames were
dangerously fast-moving it took only
three minutes for firefighters to
respond Thursday night in the Bronx but
for many trapped inside the burning five
story roughly 100 year old building it
wasn't fast enough
I'm very sorry to report 12 New Yorkers
are dead including one child as young as
one year old the search of the building
continues so we may lose others as well
officials say the victims killed range
in age from 1 to 63 years old about a
hundred and 70 members of the FDNY were
on hand to battle the fire at least 12
other people were rescued the fire
started on the first floor quickly
spread upstairs into this building
five-story building with 25 apartments
people died on various floors of the
apartment looking real bad
what a sad Christmas for everyone
stunned neighbors and victims flooded
out of the burning building and into the
sub-freezing temperatures outside just
wake up to a bunch of smoke that's it
everyone this evening hold your families
close and keep these families here in
the Bronx in your prayers
reports say city records indicate the
building had a number of safety
violations including a faulty smoke
detector detector on the first floor
that is where the fire was believed to
have originated glad absolutely
heartbreaking Don thank you very much